[Music]
[Applause]
congrats to our good buddy Ross Tucker
Westwood One CBS Sports NFL analyst
former NFL offensive lineman and made
his NFL debut yesterday with the Saints
game Saints and the Titans and uh
congratulations how did it feel being uh
an analyst breaking into the NFL
thanks Dan uh it felt awesome man it was
a lot of fun uh I actually think CBS has
done and this sounds self-serving but
they've done a great thing putting me in
the same booth with Jason McCourty right
I mean I'm an offensive guy and an
offensive lineman front seven guy
Jason's a defensive guy and a DB so it
it just works out perfectly in terms of
the you know expertise that we can both
provide during a broadcast it's my first
time doing a game with him and felt
smooth and just awesome just awesome to
be in that atmosphere everything about
it you know I'm I'm doing the game and I
hear James Brown after an update with
Boomer say let's go back to Chris Jason
and Ross it's just awesome it's awesome
good for you
um I saw where Keyshawn Johnson has the
Saints going to the Super Bowl
wow
um
I don't know if I would go that far
especially with what we saw from every
some of the other NFC teams
yesterday and just how good they looked
um I thought that clearly the saints
were better than the Titans and Carr
played much better than Tannehill did
which has got to be a little bit
concerning right I mean cars with the
Saints for the first time Tannehill's
been in in Tennessee for years and Carr
was much more comfortable in that
offense than Tannehill appeared to be I
think they got a great chance to win
their division and so that gives them a
home playoff game I don't know that I
envisioned them going on the road more
than likely and beating teams like San
Francisco Philadelphia and Dallas right
the Titans I don't understand you've
used first-round draft picks on the
potential successor for Ryan Tannehill
you're really asking him not to you know
throw interceptions so he throws three
interceptions they're a defensive team
and a running team
how long does Ryan Tannehill keep that
job
well that's the question there's no
there's no doubt about it you know I
think he showed a lot of faith in
DeAndre Hopkins on some of those throws
I think clearly the last interception
those guys just aren't on the same page
yet but then he could have had two or
three others I mean he was really
fortunate that that was not a four or
five interception day for him and he
knows I mean we talked to him on
Saturday in the production meetings he
knows the deal they took Malik Willis
two years ago they took Levis this year
I mean he's very well aware of the
situation it's the last year of his
contract
um but as Mike Rabel told us you know
the teams are always trying to get
younger cheaper better and it's the
veterans job to fight off the younger
cheaper better guy I don't know that
tanhill did that yesterday all right you
did have a moment that uh you made
social uh social media yeah get went
viral because you really love yourself
some taysom Hill the all-around one
player for the Saints here is Ross
Tucker yesterday during the broadcast
interesting to see the empty set here
a stack on the top Bill Gibson himself
the powerful Runner Jason Hill and a BYU
in his seventh year now with New Orleans
I'm not kidding when I think and when I
tell you I think he's one of the best
football players ever and Jason Hill no
I know he's not a Hall of Famer on you
that this guy can play quarterback
running back tight end he makes tackles
on special teams this guy's like Jim
Thorpe I mean can you name any other guy
that's ever done all the things that
Jason Hill did he's like the perfect
football player okay if I gave you a
mulligan would you change anything that
you said
no I don't think so I mean I might have
said
one of the best pure football players or
one of the best
all-around football players
just so that when the people like clip
it on social media or the people that
just hear that portion of it and tweet
it but no I mean I think if you listen
to the whole thing I think that's what I
meant
I mean I'm not talking about I said I'm
not talking about like Hall of Famer or
like all-time greats like Tom Brady
best of all time
foreign yeah Dan he's the closest thing
to Jim Thorpe in my lifetime now you're
older than me
but we're talking about a guy that can
run with speed run with power he has
started games at quarterback
he is a kickoff returner he makes
tackles on the punt team and the kickoff
team he plays full back running back
they split him out wide like if you're
talking about
all of the things a football player can
do right like the essence of being a
football player blocking tackling
running catching throwing
I don't I can't think of anybody else
like him I mean he's the closest thing
to a guy like Jim Thorpe or what we've
read about Jim Thorpe in my lifetime
yeah but Jim Thorpe was Elite at the
positions he played taysom Hill is not
good enough to start at any of the
positions he's not even the best player
to come out of BYU
that was the problem that I had with
taysom Hill is a great curiosity and he
does play a lot of different positions
uh but I don't think he's a a great
football player I think he's a very
versatile football player
yeah I guess like so for me
I mean he could start at every position
on the field like as a high school
player that that's incredible to me
right like to me like
if you're talking a pure all-around
football player he's like Tom Brady
obviously is the best quarterback of all
time we all know that Tom Brady can't do
half the things that Tayson Hill can do
you know what I mean like Tom Brady is
the greatest quarterback of all time
he's probably the greatest football
player of all time but when you're
talking about all around pure football
player like what you ask football
players to do
I don't know anybody that can do as many
different things as Tayson Hill which I
think makes him one of the best
all-around football players that I that
I can think of okay
I think using the word best of all time
and putting in Jim Thorpe caught in a
lot of people's attention but uh yeah I
mean like I said I think I I would have
thrown just the pure in there yeah or
the all-around he's one of the most
versatile players of all time we can all
agree on that I just don't and that and
that to me as a guy that like had to
battle
to play one position like had it had to
work all day every day my whole life to
stick around for seven years at one
position
to even get it through my skull that
there's a guy that can basically play
like seven or eight positions on a
roster is just like that he blows my
mind away and I know he's not all pro or
Pro board any I'm not talking about that
stuff I'm just talking about one of the
most unique coolest
best pure football players that I can
think of he's Ross Tucker Westwood One
CBS Sports the Ross Tucker football
podcast uh what game do you have next
weekend
uh I've got a couple actually I got a
college game for CBS Vandy and UNLV and
then I'll be in the booth for Westwood
One Sunday night Dolphins and Patriots
which will be very interesting the
dolphins that was just ridiculous
yesterday I mean it's
they are as fun to watch as any team
we've seen in a while offensively
certainly and to go on the road to beat
uh the Chargers but you know we always
overreact certainly the first week but
what is not an overreaction either
positive or negative in your opinion
uh well you're right about that and and
I think the thing that people forget Dan
is that week one is such a unique entity
unto itself because it's the first game
right and like
we didn't know what these teams would do
with their new Personnel now things
settle in a little bit more and
normalize a little bit uh I don't think
the Cowboys aren't that good like they
looked last night I think they're good
um I think what might be kind of real is
the 49ers I mean that was really
impressive the Cowboys had all kinds of
like the ball tipped they they block a
kick return for a touchdown the Niners
just came out and beat that you know
what I mean that like there was nothing
fluky or random and the Niners beat down
of the Steelers like there was with what
happened in that Cowboys Giants game
always good to talk to you and uh
absolutely thank you for having me Dan
very proud very proud that you got a
chance to do some NFL games and uh you
you certainly put in the hard work thank
you so much I appreciate it taysom Hill
is not a great football player though
thank you Ross thank you that's Ross
Tucker